Senator Lindsey Graham senator thank you
you've been you've been giving us
updates every step of the way what's the
latest
well the cabinet out bump is real the
this the biggest change in the 2018 mid
terms of political observation in North
Dakota 62 28 he should be confirmed
every race in these Trump red states
he'll by Democrat there's been a surge
by Republicans why whether you're a
trump Republican or libertarian
Vegetarian McCain Republican Romney
Republican Bush Republican you're mad as
hell because we're all United that this
is unfair what they're doing to this
good decent man cannot stand so the
Republican of the year will be a
Democrat not a Republican you've been
able to do something my friends on the
other side I could never do unite this
party and anger is real well but to do
it you had to destroy a good man in the
only way he stays destroyed if we buy
into this crap you know if every single
Sodom of the court is the only antidote
is the only judge you're a prosecutor
right when you see no corroboration
I don't prosecute okay you don't process
hola requires you to tell the accused
where it happened when it happened and
to have corroboration that it did happen
my beef is not what dr. Ford I think
she's been a used and abused my beef is
with the Democratic Party who laid in
wait betrayed her trust who didn't tell
her we'd go to California my beef is
with the fact that they've done
everything they can do to destroys life
if you don't believe is it gang rapists
if you don't believe he's a sexual
predator if you don't believe is a
stumbling bumbling drunk how about he
doesn't have the temperament this is the
one that bothers me the most
he apologized to Amy Klobuchar for
snapping at him at her what would you do
if you were accused of all these things
had your life ruined here's what I think
Amy Klobuchar should apologize to judge
Kavanaugh and his family for being part
of a smear campaign I haven't seen in
over 20 years in politics what about
these red state Democrats I think
they're toast all of them all of them
all of them politically having anybody
about the only two that are open
seemingly to even know they're toast if
they vote no and they should be
President Trump won these states
denominating serve the judges
well-qualified this is a bush guy he
worked for the Bush White House
he's as mainstream as you can get he's
been on the DC Circuit Court of Appeals
for 12 years glowing assessments of his
credibility as integrity before this
hearing now if you're going to reward
people for destroying his life by
questing his temperament then you're
setting in motion the destruction of the
judiciary to any Republican who wants to
question
Cavanaugh's temperament what you do is
rewarding the people who have put him in
this box
I've weeks from tonight the results at
this time will start flowing in yeah
and you went pretty viral your comments
on this program last night and you said
that if we if you fall one vote short
that this election five weeks from
tonight should be a referendum that the
president could Rinat Nate Kavanagh with
a new Senate and enough votes to confirm
it let's let the people decide whether
or not their senator was right in voting
no against this good man corker made an
observation that we've got two votes and
here's what I would say goodbye thank
you I got our wait on the FBI report
Lisa Murkowski and Susan Collins really
wanted the FBI to validate the
committee's work they're just about done
I'm confident both of them if there's no
change if the FBI learns nothing new
about the Ford allegation or legitimacy
to Ramirez that they're going to devote
for Cavanaugh because we've done
everything within reason and I hope Jeff
Flake will also cause he voted yes in
committee and now he's talking about
temperament and yearbook entries to
those who questioned the yearbook
entries just listen to what you're
saying you're gonna decide this man's
fate based on a yearbook entry tonight
look at ice throwing the senator from a
while devil triangle if you got a doubt
what it really means go back and talk to
judge Kavanagh himself
don't don't humiliate this it's the FBI
there was one report tonight that they
haven't talked to doctor for does there
need to talk to her after she been on
the record last thing dr. Ford needs in
my view is to go through the wringer
again she came forward to the committee
she couldn't tell us anything new in
person I think something really did
happen to her I am convinced it wasn't
Brett Kevin
if she was wrong about her best friend
being at the party what else was she
wrong about her best friend says you
know I'm not here to refute her claim
I'm just saying I've never met Brett
Kavanaugh how do you know you just had
one beer and and you can't remember
anything else you know senator you've
been a force for fairness in this side
to be this shouldn't be Republican or
Democrat sure is now
yeah you voted you're never a republican
listen don't get what they're doing
voted for both of Obama's nominees
Republican didn't act this way yeah for
a good reason
senator good to see you thank you for
he's not dead he's gonna get on the
court okay thank you